I can't wait to get drunk and turn this
thing up we're getting lit up you know
what we all got a little excited
I know I got excited looks like the
band's back yeah baby you know it's a
fun thing to do when you're listening to
this podcast is Click forward in two
hours
but listen to the beginning
R Kelly yeah
we might have ate too many mushrooms
yeah we got too many mushrooms dude
we're gonna eat this sauce no no no
we'll get through this we'll be out I
think we can drink our way out of this
you got that right I think we definitely
can Jamie what are you doing he's
nibbled on some some caps Shane are you
gone right now is that what's good
sorry I haven't talked once I've been
sitting there going yeah
it's a nice feeling I mean it feels good
I don't know how good it is for the
listener to do oh buddy
oh it's ice cubes
I give them cheap treats that's the
first addition to this group is that dog
that is a nice dog
[Music]
weird that's gross that's white people
[__] don't put it all right you're out
of the group what is this guy doing no
the dog is gonna get high
these are strong what are you guys
talking about oh they're strong the
mushrooms yeah they're strong as [__]
God damn video games are dangerous
[Laughter]